this is a production of Cornell
University hello everyone welcome and
thank you for coming to the
2023 renel Cooperative Extension in
service climate
Symposium my name is Jenna wallac and I
am an ad climate resiliency specialist
on the Harvest New York team I just
wanted to say as we get started here
feel free to um grab food and continue
eating and I'm TJ chess I'm the natural
resources educator and climate stewards
coordinator at Cornell Cooperative
Extension in Monro
County thank you all for being here
today at the end of inservice we know
it's um likely been a long week um I
just wanted to start by saying there is
a history of climate work at CCE New
York C Grant and at Cornell this is not
the first climate Symposium there have
been climate events at inservice and
related training since the
1990s in addition to these past events
there is a flurry of work happening
across the state in counties research
groups um at
Corell um field workor by Regional teams
and program work teams all taking on
different pieces of the climate change
challenge the motivation for this
particular event is
twofold first CCE Educators have
expressed interest and more
opportunities to engage on climate
topics second CCE leadership has
recognized this interest and as a result
reached out asking for this type of
event and here we are well not exactly
um the road to planning this event began
in May and we would like to thank the
climate Symposium planning committee who
you can see on the slide here for all of
the hard work and effort that they have
put into planning today and yeah so just
a round of
applause so specifically why are we here
today what's our
goal this event is an opportunity for
CCE Educators Cornell faculty
researchers and New York stakeholders
involved in climate the environment
energy Justice forestry water egg the
list goes on to continue to connect and
collabor collaboratively present uh
shared work so if you're thinking wow
that sounds like a lot you would be
right but this speaks to one of our
challenges of both climate change and
planning an event like this there are
impacts on every aspect of our society
lives and work framing this in a more
action oriented way way there are ways
that each of us can incorporate climate
work into our jobs at our local
extensions as Cornell Cooperative
Extension our mandate is to put
knowledge to work in pursuit of economic
Vitality ecological sustainability and
social
well-being we hope this Symposium will
provide CC CCE Educators on the ground
with the information and resources they
need to educate stakeholders about
practices from mitigating and adapting
to climate change as relates to this
mandate we have envisioned this event as
a way to bring awareness to The Climate
work that is already happening as well
as a starting point for future
collaborations and events it's important
to celebrate current initiatives but we
need to continue to mobilize to bring
about real
change so we're going to be showcasing
current climate work with the hope that
the following projects will provide
inspirational examples in a framework
for expanding on climate action in your
role and Community we have many experts
in many climate related topics across
CCE and Corell we also want to
acknowledge that there are important
aspects of climate work that are not
represented today um in these
presentations purely due to time
constraints um the climate Symposium is
about getting to know one another and
the resources that we already have
available to us so we hope that you will
walk away from today feeling excited and
with at least one idea of a colleague
that you can connect with after the
event or a project that you would like
to uh learn more about or
Implement and with that I would like to
introd introduce Jennifer Whitman
Jennifer Whitman is a senior extension
associate in soil and crop
Sciences she became committed to climate
in an environmental toxicology course
led by Professor Murray McBride ameritus
when she was a graduate student at
cornette and it completely changed her
trajectory she specializes in greenhouse
gas analysis for Meaningful reduction in
emissions she is co-lead of the
greenhouse gas accounting and mitigation
potential by agriculture for the New
York State Department of Environmental
Conservation
inventory she aspires to design
solutions that employ the highest best
use of our resources
equitably that J stage it's very
fast so I just want to point out that we
have three new extension agents working
on climate who were so pivotal for today
and let's celebrate the growth of the
next generation of extension of Jenna TJ
and Savannah
like
so yes we can change climate so let's
change the climate New York state is
committed to mitigating its emissions
that is clear we have a legal mandate
net neutral by 2050 we have funding for
landowners and homeowners and Farmers to
implement various Suite of activities we
have the technology and the methods and
we have a community of super neat people
like everybody in this room right here
let's make it
happen I struggle with the term climate
change to me this phrase is very passive
acceptance of a phenomena there's
extreme weather there's increased
insurance premiums there's food
insecurity and habitat and species
loss this is not a passive activity we
ourselves are constantly and actively
changing things you run out of cookies
you bake some more the compost bucket is
full you take it out you have a leak in
the roof you put a bucket under it you
look at your finances you save and then
you call somebody right this is how
we've always done
everything and why have we been changing
we have been changing endlessly this
painting in New York state is from 1826
and you'll see in the foreground two red
B
those two tiny humans are fighting for
those massive natural
resources in this painting from 1836 you
can see on the right hand side active
agriculture coming
on here you see someone
prospecting here someone is driving home
like
us and this painting just talking with
you from
Pennsylvania in 1856 let's no the year
1856 you'll see a city in the background
smoke you'll see a train and in the
foreground you'll see all those trees
because we were cutting down those trees
so let's look at the context of New York
New York has always been forested until
recently and then in the
1850s 1875 the most ever
been let's look at what that looks like
in terms of our energy consumption right
so the painting was
1856 this little divid is at 1875 right
the lowest point of our
forest this is the US energy consumption
and you'll see that wood Peaks around
1850 1860 something like that and then
of course we discovered all kinds of
fuels in New York state and elsewhere
and all of that blue is the source of
our problem we are changing things we
are pulling up historic cultures
historic ecosystems historic communities
of trees and plants and bugs and
creatures that have been stored deep
deep deep within the Earth in their own
generations of carbon sequestration and
this is the source of our problem we're
simply pulling it up and frankly if you
were stored carbon way down there
wouldn't you want to be liberated and
test out the atmosphere I mean you can't
really hold it against
them the point here is that the climate
has changed and we have actively changed
it but as evidenced in this room we are
a reflective and thinking species we are
tracking our impact we have research we
have policy we have funding and we have
people and this isn't the first time we
use to take our waste in New York City
and collect our night soil with a horse
and carriage and go like east west on
14th Street and dump it in the East
River and then go west east on 15th
Street and dump it in the Hudson River
and so what happens we have a color
outbreak and
notably New York state made its first
sewage treatment plant in Flushing New
York
I love
that we also used to have evidence of
fires on our waterways and what did we
do we came up with the Clean Water Act
and the Clean Air Act interestingly
climate was on that agenda but it didn't
happen but the point is we have
addressed this issue
too we had whole campaign for
electrification these are posters from
1937 in order to bring radio or Internet
to bring light or LEDs
right to bring fresh water and be able
to do our laundry to heat and cool our
homes and our spaces and to help farmers
electrification was in 1937 all we're
doing is reupping that
agenda so here's a personal story I grew
up in rural New Hampshire and my grandma
lived in New Jersey it took us eight
hours and now it takes about 4 and a
half but back then it took us eight
hours as we navigated those roads and
when I was about 10 you know the chore
or the way to distract me in the car
without a iPad was to make me manage the
road and the most exciting thing about
these Maps was the
legend because when it was a hatched
line it was under construction when it
was the color and when it was proposed
and I learned that lesson at about
10 that we build things that we make
things that there is something coming
and that is what we are tasked with
today past Generations did these things
for us what will we do for those that
come after us we Chang things so let's
really
change so how do we do it well we have
an overarching mandate we have methods
and mechanisms we have funding we have
each other and we continue to seek we
are
ready and that's where we introduce the
climate leadership and Community
protection act the clcpa or the climate
act here is the link to find that actual
legislation and read
it the high level content says we need a
40% reduction in greenhouse gases by
2030 and an 85% reduction by 2050 and
net neutral by 2050 that means means the
hard to decarbonized Fuels like jet fuel
or uh a burping cow that we can't quite
get to stop we have to deal with growing
more trees to sequester that remaining
15% and when we do that it can't result
in more emissions from other sectors we
can't harm other parts of our ecosystems
as we address these CL
emissions we must also do it with equity
and social justice in mind and this is a
report that Julie Suarez was part of the
diversity and racial Equity working
group report released in 20121 which was
quite eye openening for me and this was
from agen markets this is how we are
delivering on what the clcpa is asking
of
us it also mandates that we must
minimize costs and maximize an early
action so what is a reasonable cost well
DEC set out to figure out what the
social cost of carbon is and their most
recent estimates are about $130 per
metric Tent today what does that mean
anything we can do to reduce one ton of
greenhouse gases for less than
$130 saves future Generations $130 in
Damages say nothing of the emotional
impact of those
damages so this is also being Equitable
to Future
generations and of course if you look at
2050 it goes up to $180 but here we have
sort of a beginning of a reasonable
metric of what is
Affordable so in summary a 40% reduction
by 2030 85 by 2050 we have a scoping
plan it's revised every five years so if
you don't like something get on board
and start talking about it the
mitigation must be low cost it must be
Equitable it must not cause other
pollution and it must be measurable real
permanent and
verifiable 2024 is when the regulation
goes into effect for all sectors and my
apartment building in New York City for
example I have a B Energy Grade if I had
a d or F and there are plenty of
buildings that have D's and Fs their
first fine starts in 2025 they can
either invest on reducing their energy
footprint or get fined and so this is
how for example buildings in New York
City are meeting this goal alongside all
of our other
efforts and as New York a wacky like
weird State no if you want to see other
states who doing other great things look
at the climate Alliance and you'll find
those
initiatives okay so we have a mandate
how do we actually reduce our emissions
well we look at the Baseline and this is
our Baseline this is what the historic
New York state emissions are from 1990
to
2020 right we need to think about 1990
because the emissions reduction is based
on this 1990 number I don't know if you
can see
theera okay are you excited for the next
slide
okay we emitted 345 million metric tons
of carbon dioxide in
2020 but that was 15% lower than
1990 look at that we've already done 15%
of our 2030
goal
did you even feel
that so cookies in the
oven okay energy is the majority of our
problem if there's one thing we all have
to take away from this is energy is our
problem and that doesn't mean we have to
go broke or we have to get all cold
no there's tons of solutions right but
energy is our problem so don't let
people tell you agriculture is a problem
or cows are the problem energy fossil
fuels are our problem and we've got
great
Alternatives waste is also meaningful we
have to attend to it agriculture is 6%
of our emissions and Forest is our
poster child success story we're so
lucky we have this for
bank so where do we need to go here's
that same thing the same Diagnostics of
our of our past and present of where 40%
and where 85% is I guess made those
lines so don't be too
literal how do we get there we have a
445 page scoping plan you can check it
out you don't have to read all of it you
just need to read your
section and here's our emissions by
sector
this is one gigantic
piie and most of those emissions are
coming from transportation and buildings
you'll notice that the only thing for um
electricity is natural gas because 30%
of our electricity is already made from
renewable resources so of course it's
not on the side of the problem right
it's been disappeared but that doesn't
mean it hasn't appeared fiercely and
electricity is now equal with our waste
emissions which is kind of interesting
and you see agriculture is in the pink
and it's
6% so the summary of the inventory most
emissions are from buildings and
transportation agriculture is small
waste emissions are similar to
fossil-based Electric emissions forests
are a major snc we are already 15% below
1990 levels so let's rally for the next
25 to reach our 40% goal by 2030
can we do that okay so this is where my
work with Peter Woodberry comes in and
we're going to focus in on the ACT
sector can the ACT sector reduce its
emissions
40% so this is our inventory right and
you can see that actually in agriculture
we have more emissions in 2020 unlike
the state at large than we did in
1990 these are emissions broken down by
type of source with in agriculture and
these are estimates on the right hand
side of ways in which we could reduce
those
emissions with available Technologies
today we think we can reduce our
emissions roughly 50% of
50% this isn't we don't have to wait
right it's going to take work I don't
mean say that this is simple receding
which is one of the big things receding
1.7 million ion Acres of forest land
with with new trees that's no small task
right I'm not saying this is easy but
this is doable this is baking
cookies or
something we can do it what about
Cornell's campus Cornell has a goal to
reduce its be net neutral by
2035 they're almost at 50% reduction of
their total emissions they us we this
right which is amazing like these things
are doable plus do we have the resources
to help land owners and homeowners and
Farmers make change there are more than
$50 million in the next year alone to
help this happen we need to mobilize
ourselves in summary the clcpa is simply
an umbrella policy a mandate to inspire
our action there are loads of other
policies built or in progress of being
built to help move the change
forward and let's remember that the
proportion of the US Workforce in
farming in 1850 was
64% today it's only
10% yet everything Urban or rural that
we do to reduce greenhouse gases helps
current current and Future Farmers
Supply our food chain it also helps
current and future citizens have less
damage to their homes and shared
infrastructure everything we're talking
about today will directly and indirectly
benefit all citizens we are a society
born from the land on which we stand we
are in this
together and I just want us to read The
Cooperative Extension passage of the
Smith lever act in 1914 notably I got
this from man Library I love that
Library those Librarians are amazing
Cooperative agriculture extension work
shall consist of the development of
practical applications of research
knowledge instruction and practical
demonstration of existing or improved
practices or Technologies in agriculture
uses of solar energy with respect to
agriculture
1914 home economic
we're covering that today and Rural
energy we have 61% Forest land 20%
agriculture 133% idle or underutilized
land how many extension agents focus on
those idle land owners we focus on
forestry and agriculture we need to
think about those 4 million acres and
how we can activate them we have water
bodies in coastlines rural and urban
cities
how will we citizens equitably manage
these finite resources for the highest
and best use for
society what is so very great about
extension is we have the opportunity to
make a real difference in each other's
lives now and in the
future the point we have the Mandate and
the goals we have the Baseline and the
Technologies we have the funds and we
have this tremendous people power so
which piece of this pie are you and
start slicing
up
juicy I want to end with these two
pieces of art a piece of art from 1970
by Robert Indiana and this new piece
that's up right now um called in every
language there is land and langua auna
Tiara by Nicholas g g
g we must love our land
let's have a more loving relationship
with each other and our land let's work
together let's have faith in our
creative Spirit let's maintain empiric
Vigor for real mitigation let's
celebrate our successes and let's have
gratitude for every Peach person and
policy that helps us move forward made
by each other for each other on this
singular Earth so let's have a round of
applause for this whole room and all of
your efforts that you have brought here
today and all of your inspiration for
today because we are going to do
this so it's with great pleasure and an
honor to welcome our keynote speaker
Julie Suarez Julie I've chosen to
visualize your bio so that we can see
all the projects you've worked on she
serves as the associate Dean for land
grant Affairs for Cornell University's
College of Agriculture and Life Sciences
her role is to facilitate Partnerships
between the land grant mission of the
college to New York State communities
and policy
makers while at CS she's played a
leading role in establishing and
expanding programs designed to assist
New York State Farms and Food Systems
from the creation of innovation programs
like grow New York on the screen and and
the center of excellence for food and
agriculture to the expansion of ProAir
New York State integrated Pest
Management and the establishment of
Cornell small
farms veteran and Equity focused
Outreach programs and the cor Cornell
soil health and resilien SE
program she serves on the governor's
Council on food and hunger
policy she served on a the agriculture
enforcment committee Committee of the
climate leadership and Community
protection
act the industrial hemp task force for
the Department of aen markets the clean
energy for agriculture committee for
nerta and the working group for
diversity Equity inclusion and
agriculture led by commissioner ball
most recently she catalized a massive
effort which we just heard great news
about today um with uh connecting state
agencies with academic part ERS to
produce a $60 million USDA climate
connects grant for implementing projects
on the ground for New York State
landowners looking forward she is also
working to leverage Cornell Cs and Sunni
ESF to help transform her Upstate areas
into a vibrant
bioeconomy focused on food farming and
Forestry to help New York state meet our
Net Zero climate goals and she's most
proud of her two science inclined
daughters a flock of backyard chickens
and happily s sides and scoda with her
spouse please join me in well warmly
celebrating her efforts past and present
on behalf of us
all thank you so Jenny thank you so much
for your kindness your thoughtfulness
and I'm always in awe of Jenny's brain
power I've had the distinct privilege
and honor of working with Jenny and
Peter for quite some time now and every
time Jo Jenny opens her mouth something
thoughtful comes out of it so I just
really appreciate you and by the way I'm
totally humbled I only told Jenny to say
two things about me so that was a little
bit
embarrassing thank you H so really
appreciate being here today let's see if
I can figure this out Le move this down
right
sorry technology is not my strong
suit there we go thank you so here we
are today Julie Suarez quel call
obviously if I can
still what is going on
sorry you know you can do some things
but apparently the little things in life
defeat me so at any rate what is our
context today you'll all be really happy
to know I'm going to abridge the speech
because Jenny and I didn't coordinate so
you've heard many much more thorough
talks about a little bit of a quick
refresher on a New York State climate
act and our agen forestry systems goals
so little bit duplication but not too
much and I'm going to Pivot a bit I'm
going to talk to you a few Cornell cow's
updates which I think may be interesting
to you and then I'm going to talk about
a little bit about leading on climate
Cooperative Extension and I would have
to say too my own personal commitment
thank you for advancing the slides who
for did so what is our greenhouse gas
emission scope right I wanted to level
set this for everybody in this room so
you've seen this chart from Jenny
already so a little bit of duplication
again agriculture is 6% but what's
really important is that we also have to
think about methane right and I see
Peter here and I don't see Lauren but
she's probably here somewhere and uh
we're really thinking about
agriculture's contribution when it as it
pertains to methane as a greenhouse gas
in our atmosphere so from a New York
state P perspective 6% of overall
greenhouse gas emissions but
19% of methane emissions and we all know
thanks to P woodbury's great work Bob
how's great work methane has a huge
impact on our environment and on climate
change right so methane is something
that we really need to focus on next
slide please are you at some thank you I
really appreciate it like I don't know
why I couldn't do that with the mouse uh
so New York's climate act we've already
talked about this clcpa goals I think
everybody really focuses on 70%
renewable energy generation I want to
give a huge shout out to Rich Deadman
for those of you in the room earlier my
solar presentation Rich paid me to tell
me this and duplicate this for you again
Rich wrote probably one of the best
pieces of scholarship I've seen from
faculty this past year the rest of the
faculty I'm going to keep my head down
underneath this Podium for the moment
because I see a couple faculty in the
room Rich wrote along with Roberta
Nelson a fabulous article on Agra
voltaics and Rural burden and I really
just wanted to point that out to you so
that you take the time to read his work
when it talks about how the farm
community feels that concept of rural
burden uh really spoke to me personally
so I want to make sure I shouted that
out next slide and I'm not going to talk
anymore about clcpa I am however going
to talk about the scoping plan and this
is where Jenny and I inadvertently tag
team a little bit so our Dean Dr Ben
Holton was actually on the integration
analysis for the scoping plan and here's
where I want to shout out even though I
just talked about agriculture's methane
emissions the incredible potential for
agriculture to be a key part of the
climate solution right and that's
something we really all need to focus on
and internalize so when I look at the
scoping plan Jenny gave you the link I'd
encourage you to go read it for those of
you who are interested in this area this
is scenario four and while I don't know
if you can see can you guys see where I
put the arrows in the on the clip art I
don't know if you can read the text up
there but I put blue arrows on the slide
so that you would see all the many ways
that agriculture has an incredible
ability to really get us to Net Zero by
2050 right through methane mitigation
now I can't read it methane mitigation
through agricultural R&D through soil
carbon sequestration that is permanent
and verified right so what's beyond
cover cropping how do we do enhanced
photosynthesis really important work
that agriculture has a contribution to
and so I wanted to point out that when
we think about your work as you move
forward in the agricultural Community
agriculture yes maybe is not so
significant overall for greenhouse gas
gas emissions highly significant for
methane but overall huge potential to do
good in the world so that helps make
your work even more important next slide
thank you so Ag and Forestry
recommendations Jenny mentioned I had
the distinct privilege of serving on the
climate and Community leadership program
agen forestry uh subcommittee encourage
you all to read that report Peter
Woodbury Jenny were very involved in it
as were a number of our other faculty
members who brought them in for various
subcommittees what are the key areas
we're focusing on because this is
important for you and your work
importantly also it's important for you
to know where the funding agencies are
going to start investing money into
right so that we can help the farm
community take advantage of some of
these incentives so we're going to
promote sustainable Forest management
we're going to work on advancing
livestock management strategies inter
teric fermentation alternative manure
Management
Systems look to improve soil Health not
just for water quality but again I
mentioned soil carbon storage looking at
uh nutrient management particularly
focused on nitrogen reduction really
important to decrease our nitrous oxide
emissions also looking at aggro forestry
getting more value from our Woods while
we're also planting trees right and that
photo for those of you who may have gone
to arnna yesterday that photo is from
Brett ched soy's Farm on Monday which
was fantastic I had the opportunity to
go visit with him on Monday and really
seeing cows in the woods is just really
kind of fun right so also another key
component onent of our agon forestry
recommendations and I'm going talk a
little bit more about this later is to
promote something called a climate
focused bioeconomy so really important
in terms of how do we actually develop a
natural resource-based economy that
creates products that replace fossil
fuels oops I I think I figured out how
to switch it no there we go sorry thank
you now we've got dueling switches I
figured it out now so I'm good no once
we got away from the mouse so USDA
climate connects Grant and Jenny
mentioned this so thank you it really um
was a great experience and now we are
finally starting to get to the
implementation phase what does this
matter so we were able to secure a $60
million Grant from USDA under their
climate connects program and the focus
is that we're going to figure out how we
utilize that money to help get farmers
and Foresters into a more of a net zero
economy so who's on the team it's a
really broad ranging team it's the first
time in my 10 years at cows I've helped
successfully Wrangle DEC Aon markets
Soil and Water Conservation districts I
could only find suffix I couldn't find a
Statewide logo but I know Emily is here
from suffk so you'll appreciate the uh
shout out to suffk uh but it's the whole
Statewide CCE or C Soil and Water
Conservation districts and then our
academic partners of course are coral
cows Sunni ESF and Syracuse you may be
wondering why Syracuse because there's a
marketing component to this grant and
there's a really good faculty member at
Syracuse is going to look at how do you
make climate smart Commodities and make
them actually return
value so who's on the team at cows and
I'm going to shout out Dr Ichi L how
many of you have had the chance to meet
ich yet he relatively new on faculty
about a year Rich has art has okay Anu
of course really encourage you if you
have a chance to invite Ichi to come
talk to one of your seminars coming up
Ichi and I uh co-presented at a
convening in back in February with all
the National Science agencies and he's
just a really incredibly thoughtful
person and is really working hard on how
do you figure out a system that will
help measure Monitor and research and
verify I always mix up the acronym mild
dyslexia how do you do the mmvr or the
mmrv portion of actually coming up with
a way to monetize climate benefits right
so if you want to look at his website
eoad doed is going to get you there he
already has a landbased modeling tool
for uh Global carbon stocks why is this
important because as we think about how
we're going to pay Farmers to do good
practices that we want them to do or
Foresters somebody has to figure out how
you calculate the value of that
greenhouse gas either mitigated avoided
mitigated or sequestered in our soils
and so by the end of this five-year
Grant ich will be taking his tool along
with a lot of other faculty uh expertise
that's contributing into this and
turning it into a new version of what's
called commet planner so super exciting
so theoretically hopefully at the end
you're a farmer you're sitting there you
want to sell your carbon credit you pull
up an app on your phone might not be
quite that simple but let's pretend it's
going to be that simple you pull up an
app on your phone and you say okay if I
do XYZ I can actually monetize that
carbon credit so that is the overall
goal of this really exciting team
endeavor
also want to shout out Anu rajin who is
working to translate climate smart
agricultural practices into smaller
scale Farms diverse Equity Spanish first
Farms as well as really focused on Urban
environments too because how do you take
a practice and measure it in an urban
Garden which has very very small land
compared to Upstate but is still super
meaningful and also confers other
climate benefits that we want to see in
our
cities we also have Peter and Brett uh
Peter smallage and Brett chedo who are
working on the aggro forestry component
and I'm super excited about the Agro
forestry component um because again when
we talk about double cropping that's one
of a really significant ways to return
value we have Peter Woodbury Jenny
Whitman Jenny by the way I have to
compliment you that's the best head shot
picture I've seen on a cow's website
it's awesome you look so relaxed right
there so Peter and Jenny are also on
this project working on mm VR and
greenhouse gas inventory uh Kirsten Reed
from animal Sciences with a Ru office
model we have uh Ben Holton who's
actually uh we're taking off his Dean
hat for a moment and putting his
research hat on and he's working with uh
careers Family Farms at Western New York
on an enhanced weathering pilot that'll
go into the soil carbon sequestration
models Lauren Ray from prodir who will
be busily managing methane from a lot of
our New York State dairy farms Lauren's
right over there thank you along with
our colleague Bob howth uh faculty
member in EB who will also be uh part of
this grant to help measure and monitor
methane emissions from dairy farms and
we also have Jean taao who actually
should have been up with Brett and Peter
for the Agro forestry will'll be helping
measure forc um carbon sequestration all
of that comes into ichi's eventual model
so really important tool that we expect
to have I'd expect that there will be a
lot of extension involvement because
farmers are going to be really confused
right it's going to take a while to
train people how to use this so I look
forward to really helping the extension
Community connect with Ich and all of
our colleagues great work on this the
other thing that I wanted to talk to you
about super quickly is another really
exciting project we're engaged in at the
college level which is called Upstate
2.0 because you know Upstate 1.0 didn't
sound good but we figured Upstate 2.0
sounded better so what is this NSF
National Science Foundation has a really
exciting goal of transforming economies
right it always makes me chuckle when I
hear all you when you read all this
wonderful text on Grant award
announcements they want you to come up
with all these transformative projects
and I'm like okay so our goal is to
create a transformative engine for
bioeconomy and so they're called the
engines grants we have a type one Grant
which is a million doll planning Grant
and we have catalyzed a really neat team
from Cornell Korea Center for regional
economic advance ment uh they also help
run grow New York uh we have a team from
uh Sunni ESF any ESF grads here ESF is
great' been working a lot with ESF in
the past couple years and just really
fantastic team and um of course Cs and
Cornell engineering as well uh Jillian
Goldfarb and hadash because we want to
get robots into this developing
bioeconomy right we have Labor
challenges we have all these other
technical challenges in our farms and
Fields so we want to try to harness our
engineering colleagues robotic strength
right so the goal of this type one
planning Grant and it's a one-year
ideation process is to get us to a type
two which is like the mother of all big
prizes $160 million of money for faculty
members to play around with right so all
the faculty members in the room were
like who $160 million for R&D that's
exciting right but the goal is to really
help get us to the R&D that's going to
be necessary to support a b bio economy
one that is inextricably linked to our
forest to our Farms to our food
producers one that is significantly more
just and more inclusive and one that
includes and relies on uh use inspired
research if you want to learn more about
it I put the website
there and what is the idation process so
we've been having a lot of really fun
road trips so part of our idea for this
NSF Grant is to think about Net Zero
dairies right so what is the actual
research and tools that our farmers and
our food manufacturers need to reduce
their energy and to actually produce
products that we all want to eat uh
three times or more a day but to do so
in a net zero fashion right so we've
been working with kuga Milk ingredients
and the 21 Farms that surround kuga Milk
ingredients to think about milk all the
way from the farm to the processing
plant so super exciting concept other
Concepts we're talking about is CA and
protected agriculture culture really
important to think about as our climate
changes and we need to grow more food in
the New York state area and of course
the North East area as well what are the
types of Investments and what scales do
we need for for Growers to truly be
successful in CA and protected
agriculture uh my robotic friends my
engineering friends are really
interested in this concept of a center
for agricultural autonomy harnessing AI
which is you know I have not used chat
GPT I don't know how many of you in the
room have use chat GPT I know Kyle
has but um you know how do we get AI to
work better for our data and also create
really fun robots like Yan's robot which
you see pictured on there at agretech
help to help um uh
Farmers eventually Harvest but right now
with disease detection looking at
sustainable Aviation fuels biobased
processing materials right how do we
actually utilize hemp and of course
we're really FOC focused on doing things
better than we have in the past being
inclusive and so we've had a lot of
meetings with our tribal Partners on
this grant which has been something
that's been deeply inspiring and
meaningful to me and we're talking about
how we make sure that we engage with
tribal communities so that it's two-way
learning so science-based Solutions I
did want to a shout out to Yolanda
because they said to Yolanda you know
what does CCE really want to hear so I'm
putting you on the spot Yolanda
Yolanda's like oh hopefully I said
something good so shout out to Yanda who
said you know what we really want to
hear or know at least a little bit more
about what faculty are doing so I took a
list I took a look at who's coming to
this and I wanted to just shout out
faculty to keep an eye on who are
working in this area and I'm not going
to go through their research but I
encourage you to keep your eye on them
so methane mitigation Joe mcfaden and T
fermentation we will soon have methane
Chambers on this campus I say soon
because so far it's been like October
and then November and now maybe what
Jason what's the next estimate December
is January we will soon have those on
our campus to be able to do the science
that we need to give Farmers real
science-based solutions Karine Kings is
doing fabulous work on on Farm research
with nitrogen emission reduction really
encourage you to follow uh her work for
those of you who have farmers who may be
interested in doing on-farm uh trials
please see Jason there's my commercial
for you um great work that is doing soil
carbon sequestration with permanence
right cover crops are great they are
wonderful wonderful wonderful tools but
we need to have ways to store carbon
more permanently in our soils and that's
going to be through things like biochar
you see sort of see on that slide one of
uh mobile paralysis unit installed on
Doug Young's Farm in Spruce Haven with
Johannes Layman so we're thinking about
biochar we're thinking about enhanced
weathering forestry and Agro forestry of
course really want to shout out some of
janga's work work he's a relatively
newer faculty member encourage you to
get to know him and understand what he's
doing in our forest kind of backpack
measurement systems that are going to be
really important for our future climate
resiliency plant breeding a number of
Faculty members working in that but lur
gun if anybody's ever talk to Laura gun
amazing work I can't completely describe
it but she's working on enhanced plant
photosynthesis so how do you change the
the plant biology to make sure that the
plant can actually take carbon more
effectively from the atmosphere grow
deeper roots and Stor it into our soil
so really night neat plant biology work
greenhouse gas accounting I've talked
about Ichi Peter and Jenny working in
this area and then of course we also
have to think about biodiversity I know
in the a world we don't think about
biodiversity as much but super important
work that we need to be thinking of I've
already shouted out Rich so I'm going to
skip over my shout out to you again rich
but a lot of people working in AGR
voltaics that will be very important as
we hit to 70% but now here I'm going to
stop with the information overload and
say Where Do We Go From Here Right uh so
I wanted to just share with you some of
and I don't often do this but so I'm
going to take my moment in the spotlight
to kind of be a little bit philosophical
for a moment so you'll have to bear with
me but where what are our Farmers
feeling today right they're feeling
pressures from consolidation and
concentration I'd encourage you to read
the USDA seed consolidation report quite
uh scary for those of you who are
worried about consolidation and
concentration in the a input uh Arena
they're concerned with high input costs
inflation of course is coming down now
but it's still at levels that we've not
seen and the thing about prices rising
is that they may start to go down but
they never go down to the exact same
area where they were before right we see
incredible disruptions in Supply chains
and markets Cheryl is or is not in this
room I don't know but the farm to school
team has been uh dealing with a lot of
talk this whole week on the cardboard
shortage right because we're still
seeing seeing uh massive disruptions in
our Marketplace we have climate and
weather challenges let alone climate
change right our farmers are also
dealing with climate
adaptation um we see this concept of
rural burden and the concept of urban
burden right we don't always understand
each others in rural areas we feel like
we've been extracted and in urban areas
we also feel like we've had a very
extractive economy right so these
pressures are weighing on us and of
course we have an incredible amount of
filter Bubbles and a lack of
science-based real information I think
the most recent thing I was chatting
about with my spouse at the at the
dining room table last night was an
actual real question saying that solar
energy is actually more harmful to the
environment than
Nuclear So we have a lot of um uh
information out there in The Ether that
is not accurate right we have regulatory
constraints and we have incredible
global trade partner shocks and we have
overall certainties in the world in
which we live today but a very wise
person once said to me it is human
nature to be afraid of change and it is
particularly human to be afraid of the
incredibly rapid pace of change that we
see in all areas of Our Lives from local
to Global communities right so if we
recognize that that change and that fear
of change is very real the fear of each
other it kind of Fosters so much of we
see that's troubling in society today
from disinformation to active strife and
a decline of Civic engagement bet you
didn't expect a political scientist to
be talking about decline in Civic
engagement in a climate Forum right but
it matters right so where do we go from
here if all those are factors that are
facing the communities in which we serve
where do we go from here and because I
tend to read an awful lot um I would
highly recommend this book To You by Lee
McIntyre who's an MIT faculty member uh
this came out I think a year or so ago I
don't don't entirely recall I've passed
it around to a bunch of my colleagues at
this point I'm not even sure who has it
at this moment in time but I'd really
recommend that you read this because
everything that extension does is a
solution to this interraccial problem in
society today of people's um
unwillingness to confront change and
their fear and the constant
misinformation we see right so what are
the key lessons from this book have
conversations not
confrontations right if if you're
talking to somebody who really truly
doesn't believe in climate change you
are not going to change their opinion if
you confront
them have long-term non-extractive
relationships super key right that's a
key issue of what we have in extension
factual and respectful continued
dialogue and
engagement and then piercing the filter
bubbles that we all live in practicing
empathy and authentically listening
these are the key lessons from this book
and from life in general how to actually
talk to people in your communities about
climate change and misinformation and
fear right so how do we make a
difference right this is this is uh my
being a little bit snarky um but I'm
going to share with you my own personal
philosophy and I think it's kind of the
height of arrogance to put your own
picture on a slid set that you're giving
just so you know I'm acknowledging that
however I did it because I want to say
this is my personal commitment you may
or may not choose to share this and it's
entirely up to you so how do we make a
difference in this world in which we
live and put science-based Solutions
first when you're conversing with people
listen with compassion lead with
optimism right because that is so
important for the world in which we live
and I deal with talking to so many
farmers who are very unoptimised that it
is important to always retain your
optimism be relevant to all of your
community and when I say all I do you
mean all of your community including
people who may or may not look like you
right super important to be more
inclusive provide Education Without
judgment or arrogance right and we
always remember we learn as much as we
teach and so there's my acronym
everybody
ready
score right when we think about how you
want to be in life that is certainly my
commitment and so I will just leave you
with the thought that really it's really
important for us all in this room when
we're wearing Cornel red shirts to be
the change that you wish to see right
because we are not going to make a
difference in climate unless we Model
Behavior ourselves so do not ever hit
people over the head with climate issues
but look for ways to partner reach out
to your Soil and Water Conservation
districts reach out to others you know
provide science-based and practical
advice that effectuates behavioral
change and echoing Jenny's far more
inspirational call I will say we will
indeed get there together and we don't
have much more time to waste so I look
forward to the years
ahead thank you Julie for that
thoughtful and inspirational
presentation Dean Ben Holton wasn't able
to make it to today's event but he did
record remarks for everyone
here hello everybody Welcome to the CCE
inservice climate Symposium I'm Benjamin
Holton the Ronald P Lynch dean of the
College of Agriculture and life sciences
and I also happen to be a climate
scientist who studies agricultural
sustainability now we know the climate
challeng is here it's bad it's getting
worse and we can solve it but it's going
to take Collective action and new
Innovations to support the state through
the incredible issues that are in front
of us in in New York we are already
witnessing the devastating impacts of
growing weather extremes historic floods
droughts that are localized Rising
temperatures in heat waves and Rising
Seas this is challenging our farmers and
producers our infrastructure our natural
resources and of course our communities
so we need to focus on resilience
resilience is where adaptation
mitigation and societal transformation
come together in sets of solutions that
can bend the carbing curve bend the
warming curve and promote uh resilience
for food for people and for
infrastructure at Cornell we have
launched the 2030 project which is
dedicated to harnessing the Firepower of
Cornell's intellectual expertise across
all Colleges and Schools to help support
real ambitious and practical climate
Solutions we're focusing on farms of the
future and food of the future energy of
the future material Goods of the future
and of course societies of the
Future these core areas are fundamental
to translating research on this campus
to the broader world and will be
fundamental to thinking about our land
grant mission in New York state
however the University's reach is
greatly diminished without the sheer
expertise and localized knowledge of
Cornell Cooperative
Extension that's why I'm so delighted
that you're meeting today to focus on
climate change and the many issues and
opportunities uh in front of us key
areas of focus in CCE that are
especially important right now including
the energy transition finding co-
benefits for AGR voltaics working with
communities and local decision makers so
we can find win-win Solutions and create
a robust energy portfolio that preserves
Farmland protects the environment and
inspires Local Economic value of wind in
solar and geothermal
power working across CCE soil Health
practices continue to be incredibly
important to our farmers
as they build resilience into their
cropping systems this includes a focus
on carbon sequestration in forests and
farmland soil and practices that empower
the co-benefits of healthy soils with a
resilient climate
future work on Net Zero
dairies uh is also incredibly important
the research that's going on through our
regional teams as they educate our dairy
uh community and such important programs
as ProAir this is a great opportunity
for the state to lead in realized
methane emission reductions and Drive
circular systems in a sustainable Dairy
operation
future finally supporting communities
people as they adapt to extreme weather
to create localized Food Systems to
support nutrition and Community
Development and Youth educ
education work that's happening across
the state and especially in our cities
including in urban agriculture is
incredibly important to driving
resilience and empowering our local
cultures to create a climate smart and
adaptive future not only for today but
for our kids the challenge of climate is
great so we must be greater I believe in
the power of innovation teamwork and
Collective a
action our superpower is collaboration
and Cornell University combined with
Cornell Cooperative Extension is unlike
any in the world I'm so grateful for
your dedication to climate Solutions and
wish you a wonderful set of meetings and
encourage you to take this Challenge on
with bold thinking Big Ideas and
optimism and hope because we need that
if we're going to chart a pathway
forward in a climate resilient future
where Solutions not only work here in
New York state but radiate around the
world so now we're going to transition
we're going to begin our lightning talk
section
um so as you can see in your program
there's four sections of the lightning
talk um responding to impacts of climate
change in New York state forest and
Farms a forest and Farms B and lastly
but not least energy and
community so there will be topics I
mentioned this earlier that there will
be topics that are not going to be
mentioned today some of those topics
include oceans and estuaries wind
rooftop solar
EVS hard to decarbonize Fuels irrigation
land use planning biodiversity there's a
few more there's also important topics
that we didn't have time to cover today
um we hope that with our next
educational Gathering that we can
highlight all the topics that we missed
today um we'd like you to keep in mind
that during the lightning talk section
these are just some extremely brief one
minute introductions to a topic by
having 30 plus of these we're hoping
that everyone become can become more
aware of the wide bread of work that's
happening across the state and identify
a couple projects that relate to your
own current work your own projects that
you could um then Implement in the
future so I'd like to thank you to our
wonderful presenters that we have today
that all agreed to do
this um so I just want to mention that
there will not be time for a Q&A during
our lightning talks but there will be
opportunities for discussion and
networking during intermissions between
our lightning talk sections um we
encourage that you write your questions
down you'll notice that on your program
uh the cornal net IDs are provided so
you could directly reach out to the
speaker each speaker has chosen one key
resource that they'll share and I think
it's oriented in the center of the
slides um these are available the QR
codes you have you'll have access to the
slide on the back the program on a QR
code also so do not worry if you can't
catch the QR code while it's
up so now we're going to jump into the
first lightning talk section which is
responding to impacts of climate change
in New York
state so when responding to the impacts
of climate change we must understand
that climate change has cascading
impacts on our social and natural
worlds climate change can cause extreme
heat which alone may not may not cause
malnutrition however extreme heat can
cause drought and poor working
conditions which then can cause less
food to be cultivated which then can
cause for Less food to be shipped and
which then leads to food insecurity
ultimately leading to malnutrition
that's just one of many examples we
could use so this section we're going to
be highlighting work that's done by our
Cornell and CCE colleagues to respond to
these impacts of climate change
the section will provide resources that
can be used and implemented at your own
extension to respond to climate change
impacts on a local
level our response must be Equitable and
just to be
sustainable I'd like to suggest
partnering with uh neighboring counties
and communities sharing some of these
resources and ones that you create
amongst each other framing climate
change regionally to help Implement
long-term sustainable actions to
climate impacts as communities that are
in these same watersheds in these same
bio regions they deal with a lot of the
same impacts so we have to mobilize
together so with that let's start our
lightning
talks hey they put the meteorologists
first to do the lightning pox so um I'm
I'm artig atano from the Department of
Earth and Atmospheric science and I
think the best way you can remember me
in a minute is the data Guide so I run a
uh data center called the northeast
regional climate Center and kind of
there what we do is take this data and
don't just give you data but put this
data into tools so two examples there
the first one is an egg example on how
we can use changing climate conditions
current climate conditions to help
producers uh determine when they can
best put in cover crops and things like
that so that's a cover crop tool we've
worked with as part of climate smart
farming and the bottom is actually a
tool that we've been working with some
colleagues on to help local communities
plan for climate change and their Hazard
mitigation plans in their vulnerability
assessments so in a very good graphical
way there's kind of the thing on the the
left under mad we call that our Mad Libs
kind of takes texts and kind of things
you could cut and paste along with
Graphics into your things so I got my 15
seconds so
next all right well we go from the the
air and the sky down to the soils
because I'm a soils person um I'm Deb
Allen I'm extension associate in um soil
and crop sciences and with the Cornell
soil health program but for the last two
years and other role I've had is serving
as co-chair with Dr Allison katrian on
the agricultural chapter of the upcoming
New York State climate impact assessment
report and so this is an update of the
2011 climate report for everyone who is
familiar with that Dave wolf who's a
professor amerus at Cornell was the one
who led the agricultural chapter so this
is actually um focusing eight different
sectors of the New York State economy
and agriculture only being one of them
um and so this is bringing together all
the latest science um around climate
change and all these different sectors
really important to the New York State
economy and so agriculture has a been a
big component of this and really the
focus of this updated assessment report
is the adaptation side of things not
really focusing on the mitigation side
which the climate report did but
adaptation so these are just some
pictures um across Farms in New York
state around adaptation strategies being
implemented so thanks very
much hi I'm carollyn clocker and I am
the environment and energy program
leader at Cornell Cooperative Extension
in Duchess County um and I have the
privilege of coordinating a program of
CCE dutches Columbia green olster
Rockland and renier counties called the
CCE climate resilience partnership and
it is a partnership also with New York
State DEC Hudson River Estuary program
and the New York State Water Resource
Institute here at Cornell University
with support from the New York State
Environmental Protection fund and
through this collaboration CCE staff
provide technical support to
municipalities uh in the Hudson Valley
to complete uh adaptation actions of the
New York State climate smart communities
program so for example this includes uh
reviewing a municipalities codes
ordinances and plans and making
recommendations on how they can include
more resilience measures in these uh
items it also includes uh drafting heat
emergency plans with communities
updating a community commities emergency
preparedness information and educating
their residents about that
information crafting climate resilience
Visions with communities and much much
more um and so since uh yeah since 2018
the climate resilience partnership has
worked with that many communities
thanks hello Andy Turner today I'm New
York State 4 this this is about a really
important 2020 2 4 National survey of
teens that really showed that we need to
step it up and get youth more involved
in climate change Solutions more than
80% of the youth believe that more
action is needed now to address climate
change that they will be forced to make
major life decisions such as job choices
career choices where they live and even
if they want to start a family based on
climate realities however the good news
90% are ready to be part of the solution
and believe that small actions to
improve the environment can have a big
impact long term New York State 4 has
piloted a strong program with teens
called curbing our carbon environment
appetite which helps youth to understand
the science of the carbon cycle carbon
sequestration and the role of consumers
and producers in building a healthy
sustainable food supply to learn more
contact Dr mingla teron Mong she's our
New York State 4 Health wellness and
food system specialist let's get our
youth involved in the solutions to
climate change in New York state thank
you very
much
good afternoon my name is Yul kaker with
CCE orange where I am the resilience
educator Community educator I conducted
a pilot study during which we used a
healing informed social imaginary as a
tool to build resilient communities that
regenerate
well-being and the findings that we came
up with were threefold the first one was
that individuals need time and space to
integrate their understanding and
insights around trauma informed
practices and those also include based
or resulting from extraction based
models the second was that individuals
are looking for skill building
opportunities so that they can apply
what they're learning and the third one
was to build community at every level
including in the classroom the um among
uh among their colleagues and also in
our
community thank you good afternoon my
name is Mike Huffman I'm a professor
amerus from the College of agan Life
Sciences I'm going to talk about the
power of
food we need a great climate change
Awakening especially in US you get it
but a lot of people do not get it how
about using the power of food to make
climate change relevant to everyone we
eat several times a day sometimes many
too too many times a day but it's with
us every day we love it and the stories
we can tell about our favorite foods on
our Staples are nearly
endless this is what I do food is the
perfect climate change messenger a
recent survey we did showed that
regardless of political affiliation
people care are concerned about their
climate CH climate change impacts on
food choices and they want to learn more
an audience awaits this is not another
Doom and Gloom story but one that
Empower people to act on climate change
one step you can all take start just
talk about it have a meal with others
and talk about what's happening in front
of you on your plate and by saving our
favorite foods maybe we can keep the
planet
liveable hi I'm Danielle Eisman I'm a
lecturer in the Brooks School of Public
Policy I teach on the masters of public
administration program and I am working
with um a local group of stakeholders as
well as my students to explore risk and
vulnerability among residents living in
manufactur Ed housing communities as
well as um outside of those communities
and other manufactured housing what
started out as looking at how to improve
Energy Efficiency in manufactured
housing has now grown into um a much
bigger project where we're starting to
recognize that the changing climate
really affects an already vulnerable
group of of people um that struggle with
affordability Wellness
Transportation um higher uh energy costs
in comparison to people living in uh
site Built Homes and so we've started to
collect kind of Baseline data to really
understand the scope of what's Happening
here and we're hoping to turn this into
a policy tracker in the future as well
as um working with residents to improve
these issues thank
you hi everybody I'm Alison CH Sean so
nice to see so many of you that I work
with um I want to talk first about the
Cornell climate stewards program it's a
12we curriculum um based on Master
Gardener volunteer program that we've
developed and we teach volunteers about
climate science impacts working with
local government and working with TJ we
developed a climate Justice module
mitigation and adaptation we've trained
over Educators from 14 counties in New
York in New York state and 100
volunteers and we're planning to run
this again in 2024 and next slide three
projects that I work on related to
climate smart agriculture with art Deano
we developed the climate smart farming
program and many of the educators are
here in the room um that is a great tool
for you the second is a dairy climate
adaptation fellowship program that we're
running starting in January 2024
recruiting Dairy Farmers now and the
third I'm fund just starting work on a
new AI climate Institute for climate
smart agriculture with Johannes Leman so
thank
you hi I'm Lindsay I'm a professor in
biological and environmental engineering
here at Cornell uh we work on technical
assessment and solution design for the
energy transition uh basically one one
of the most relevant examples to you is
thinking about what are the
vulnerabilities and reliability
challenges of the New York State grid
under the proposed transition with the
clcpa next slide um you can see here in
the top left this is sort of the
deployment of the Renewables across the
state what we in this project what we've
done is developed a um a realistic
digital twin of the New York State grit
we built out the clcpa according to
these potential Investments and
allocations among space we Implement
electrification of transportation and
buildings and then what we do is we run
it uh for hourly operations hour to hour
to hour for over 20 years under
different climate uh and weather Futures
and we look to see uh where potential
problems might lie based on Technology
based on climate and weather changes
combinations of those not for the
purposes of saying there's problems here
in Doom and Gloom but to say okay if we
can identify these potential
vulnerabilities and reliability problems
let's start developing uh Solutions now
before they become a crisis thank
you thank you everybody that just gave
those lightting talks you guys are
awesome um so we have we have these
prompts after each
talk and um basically what we want to do
is to have and start a conversation so
we encourage everyone to talk to people
that they haven't met before as well as
friends so for those on Zoom we
encourage that you add your thoughts on
the poll on the chat while um you're
working in brainstorming there are
Refreshments still in the foyer so
you're welcome to go do that use the
restroom but for our first
prompt if you can hear me clap once you
hear me clap twice sweet I learned that
from 4 so the first prompt is turn to
your neighbor and talk about one thing
that you're hopeful
for all right you can hear me clap once
you can hear me y'all climb
it all right we are going to transition
to our next lightning talk section thank
you afternoon
friends we are going to continue in the
same pattern each speaker will introduce
themselves but we're switching the topic
now to more forests and farms and it's a
hard act to follow people that first
session was pretty
awesome but we're going to break this
one into two sections we'll have another
15 minute break in the middle of the
forest and farm
section so I want to kick us off with a
little uh a little talk from myself I'm
Kitty O'Neal I'm a field crops and soil
specialist uh up north on the North
Country Regional a team team with
CCE um and I'm an original member of
Alison chath Chan's climate smart
farming team along with our timer Laura
mcder uh so I'm going to kick us off
we're going to hear five or six one
minute talks from our peers about how
we're working toward climate resilience
across farms and Fields and forests Agro
forestry we'll take a brief break we'll
get another question to think about
during the break and then we'll come
back together for another six or seven
talks about fields and farms and forests
uh hearing from our peers about their
respective areas of
expertise I wanted to talk to you today
about how to do this rather than what
I'm doing per se I'll use myself in his
example but I wanted to talk about how
to figure out where you should sort of
dig in and get started on doing some of
this work yourselves to me that's the
hardest
part so I wanted to tell you about uh a
couple of ideas um I want to recommend
visiting the Cornell natural and working
lands website and looking at several of
the papers there but most specifically
the 13 strategies paper that Peter
Woodberry and Jenny Whitman have written
it's kind of like a to-do list you can
pick something off the list of 13 things
and see if it fits o if it overlaps with
your plan of
work in the same way I would recommend
looking at the New York State a and
markets clent resilient Farms website
that's the the QR code in the center
here and look at their um RFP for the
CRF program and see if that that's
almost like a to-do list see if any of
that stuff overlaps with your plan of
work and then so now though comes the
hard part you can pick some stuff up of
there that overlaps with your planed
work but now is the hard part I picked
something off the list I knew I wanted
to contribute to climate res resilience
for my North Country Farms but you can't
just work on climate resilience or
climate adaptation or climate mitigation
you have to narrow down your focus you
have to get really specific you have to
really really
focus so for me soil Health was an
obvious overlap with my plan of work but
soil health is still too big you can't
just work on soil Health you have to go
even more specific and narrower than
that so I knew on my farms uh soil
health is a key component of climate
resilience that falls within my plan of
work we need soils to remain in place
and continue to function in the face of
the weather we know to expect now Farm
needs Farms need to know how to deal
with this so first thing we need to do
is figure out how to measure soil
compaction well I wanted to work on soil
compaction one aspect of soil Health you
got to be able to measure it well so we
took a stab at a protocol I began
collaborating with quirine kering's
nutrient management sphere program to
look at the relationship between soil
compaction severity and historical yield
within a field next slide please there
we go I'll talk about these results with
anyone who's interested uh for now it's
just a pretty picture of some of some
cool data our measurement protocol
worked we were able to figure out uh we
found a relationship uh while compaction
is very serious everywhere we discovered
it is consistently worse in the
consistently low yielding areas of a
field compared with the consistently
High yielding areas of a
field um and we've expanded this project
now uh out more in Northern New York but
also into Western New York and Central
New York working together with uh that
lab a capable lab staff we have a farm
viability Grant now in addition to the
original Northern New New York EG
development program Grant going forward
now we have this protocol that Works to
look at relationship between soil
compaction and anything we pick anything
we choose we can look at uh patterns uh
and figure out strategies from that
pattern to mitigate greenhouse gases and
find a climate solution so my last thing
my last Point here is you have to focus
focus focus down to something specific
you may feel
like that's I'm working on this tiny
piece that really I should be doing more
right but don't worry about it that is
necessary that's an essential part of
how to do this I think thank you hi I'm
Sharon Bachman Aon natural resources
educator with Cornell Cooperative
Extension in Erie County our tree work
is interwoven with climate stewardship
Community gardening food security and
insur in urban food forests I recently
participated in a CCE educator cohort to
offer the Cornell climate steart
training since offering the training
I've worked with our seven new
volunteers to support their climate
Steward projects some of them expr
expressed interest in community trees I
have connected them with our existing
Community Tree Steward program started
thanks to the interest of one of the
master Gardner volunteers that we
trained in
2014 our resource that we're sharing is
our our community tree Steward resources
online in Moodle thanks to some funding
we received from New York State
DEC we look forward to working with Erie
County on a current urban forestry
initiative that supports food forests
and Associated Workforce
development Guided by principles and
permaculture we value diversity and seek
integration and interconnectedness in
our extension programming thank
you hi everybody I'm rich stemman I
don't know how I can describe an entire
research project in one minute but I'm
going to give a try and first I got to
embarrass Julie Suarez she's been
calling me out all day so thank you
Julie for helping to put together the
climate and applied Forest Research
Institute um basically the punchline of
this project is you know how we're going
to put solar panels everywhere and
that's going to solve The World's
problems well we're also going to grow
mature Forest everywhere and that's
going to solve The World's problems and
so so there are these a lot of um a lot
of estimates about how much land is
available for growing mature forests to
sequester carbon um basically this
project is about the idea that those
estimates are wildly overoptimistic if
we don't have a sense of whether land
owners want to play the game and so
basically what we did we put together a
survey um of land large land owners St
Lawrence Valley Southern Tier and
basically looked at their willingness to
grow mature Forest good news bad news um
good news at least two-thirds were
somewhat willing bad news and that's in
principle right bad news is when it gets
down to the weeds are you willing to
fence are you willing to do deer
exposures are you willing to do all of
these other things that are going to be
required to do it it dropped but but um
the uh the thing's there uh click on it
whole report seven
P everyone my name is Gabriel Smith I'm
the Cornell Cooperative Extension aggro
forestry educator here in compin County
my work Statewide focuses on integrated
Chestnut and hazelnut Agro forestry
systems specifically Aly cropping and
Silva pasture which are two of the five
defined USDA practices within Agro
forestry these two practices however do
not have practice standards within the
nrcs here in New York state CCE however
does offer support for all five
practices including Forest farming like
varying Forest buffers wind breaks with
Incredible demonstrations like shitake
production jining trials at ARK and of
course Cornell small farms providing
tremendous support for Agro forestry
through education next slide please we
would like to offer more training for
service providers Educators and farmers
at every stage to be able to use Agro
forestry practices so that New York
State as a whole can realize multiple
benefits across the economic and
ecological landscape and Farmers on the
ground can experience greater economic
stability and increased land Health
thank
you hi everyone my name is mallerie Hall
and I'm an urban Garden specialist um
living in Buffalo go bills and I'm
working in Erie and Monro counties um
I'm able to compare the urban growing
scene in both of those counties and
buffalo has a pretty robust um Urban
Farm scene there with a lot of urban
farms and over 100 Community Gardens um
contra Ed to what's happening in Monroe
County and Rochester where there's not
really any for-profit Urban Farms there
but more of of um more of the community
garden happening there and even though
there's different things happening in
the two cities um they both face the
same struggles with policy issues and M
Municipal challenges and they both have
really strong community and nonprofit
support
you hi I'm Graham s I'm the A and
horiculture issue leader at CC Tomkins
my colleagues today have talked about
the specific programming we're doing
Gabe and Jan derario and I'd like to
just share a couple of the reasons
behind our focus on dni in that work
that
slide indigenous land Holdings have
lower rainfall and higher incidents of
extreme heat on average and marginal
lands are all at greater risk from
climate-driven weather extrems and in
New York these are often Prime sites for
aforestation reforestation and Agro
Forestry Gabe silver pasture work is of
service to Farmers working with this
kind of land people of color face many
barriers to farming including difficulty
accessing ecological agricultural
education that would teach climate
resilient farming methods since
internships are often unpaid and so
inaccessible to those without
generational
wealth and food insecurity projected to
rise due to climate change is much
higher in communities of color in our
community farmers of color are working
to address this by developing Innovative
Financial models to make their food
accessible to food insecure families who
could not otherwise afford it Jan's
payment foros system Services work is
just one example of this kind of work
thank
you hi I'm Peter Woodbury glad to see
you all here today uh so New York state
has a mandate as we've heard of Net Zero
greenhouse gas emissions by 2050 and
this will require removing carbon
dioxide from the atmosphere as well as
reducing
emissions so growing native trees is an
natural and proven way to remove carbon
from the
atmosphere we found that there are 1.7
million Acres of former agricultural
land that might be suitable and
potentially available for for tree
planting that's
SL so some counties have much more land
available than others so find your
county
here uh there's many challenges to
reforestation including the cost and as
Rick stman mentioned uh landowner
preferences as well the cost however is
lower than the damages from climate
change so in summary planting native
trees is an important and coste
effective natural climate solution
thanks hi everyone my name is Jan
derario I'm the payment for ecoystem
services educator at CC Tomkins um PES
programs can incentivize and reward
Farmers for environmental benefits that
they provide through their Land
Management so things like carbon
sequestration and soils and trees that
are integrated into um their Farms as
well as improved water quality increased
biodiversity reduced erosion there are
existing programs out there you may have
heard of carbon markets but they're
generally focused on larger Farms that
are doing Fel crop operations and we see
that there's a gap um where there's
limited opportunities for bipac and
beginning Farmers to access these
programs so next slide please um here at
CC Tomkins we're working on a pilot
program with six farmers in the county
to better uh to co-create the pilot and
better understand their priorities in
long-term programming um majority of the
participants are bipac and beginning
Farmers um here you can see our
volunteers taking soil cores for
car thank
you that was pretty amazing we're going
to take another short break with a
discussion question what is an area of
Cl work you hadn't considered before
today or a new idea or approach that
caught your interest to that you might
be able to implement in your own
Community we'll see you back in
15 so we got another round of forests
and farms uh 3D Live Tik toks for you um
these are other people's jokes I'm just
repeating them microphone um so to lead
us off we have Liz
Higgins another after along crop
insurance talk everybody's favorite no
but this is the year actually um this is
the first year I've done work on crop
insurance I'm Elizabeth Higgins I'm an
extension associate with the Eastern New
York commercial Hort team and um yeah so
I've been doing work on crop insurance
for many many years at Cornell but most
recently with um Brad Rickard and Jenny
ifth and some folks at ERS really
looking at uptake of crop insurance with
specialty crop farms um we interviewed
farms in New York about crop insurance
whether or not they had prop Insurance
most of them like no it's too expensive
no it doesn't pay anything and we're
like have you ever tried to look at it
have you ever like actually figured out
how much it cost and most them said no
but I just I just know it doesn't work
and so we we so we went and look and
actually USDA um has been improving prop
Insurance quite a bit uh changed the
slide we've looked at a report and we've
been comparing like sort of one of the
things that's confusing is there's a lot
of different policies but there's a new
one I want you all to know there's whole
Farm Revenue insurance but now there's
the whole Farm Revenue micro insurance
program that one um the paperwork is
easy um tell your farmer friends and um
look at the report and if you have
questions call me
bye my name is Carolyn Marner I work
with Tony Tomaso at the so at the this
is what I get for trying to like make it
really fast M soil and crop Sciences we
work on Weeds which are a big problem
for our Farmers especially with the
uptick in herbicide resistant weeds that
are making them harder to manage on
conventional Farms with climate change
we're expecting to see shorter
Management Windows due to our changing
weather conditions we're also expecting
to see changes in our herbicide efficacy
due to the various climate factors like
increasing carbon dioxide and higher
temperatures and we'll be seeing new
weeds coming into the state from the
south as the climate warms and we'll
also be seeing changes in
competitiveness with our crops weed by
weed crop by crop some better some worse
so we've done a systematic review of the
literature on these topics and we're
trying to synthesize that information
for our New York Dairy and field crop
Farmers so that we can support effective
weed management into the future in our
changing
climate H everyone my name is Kyla
PaPeRo I'm the recycling and composting
educator at CCE in scity County which a
Teensy little County but it's highly
populated just Northwest of Albany um in
Connect I run two Community compost
stations and this year we begin
collecting food scraps at one of the
local elementary schools and altogether
we've diverted over 20,000 lbs of food
waste in just over a year um the
diversion is so important because
sending our food scraps to the landfills
breaks them down anerobic releasing
harmful greenhouse gases like methane
which we've heard about and composting
allows us to eliminate that factor while
creating an amazing and useful finished
product next slide please at the school
we're composting to create soil for the
school Gardens where the farm to school
program will help them grow delicious
healthy food and at the community
compost stations so finish compost will
be fertiliz uh fertilizing our on-site
Urban Farm which is run by local high
school students uh all summer as they
learn how to grow healthy food for our
community these skills are introduced
and reiterated through our many classes
um mine on various methods of composting
and my colleagues seed diser classes
showing our community that we all have
the skills to recycle resources save
money help the planet feed ourselves and
each other thank
you hi everyone my name is Casey demer
I'm the communications manager for the
Cornell small farms program as we all
know the majority of farms in New York
are small and they are on the front line
of climate change impact one extreme
event could wipe them out these farmers
are working to maintain their Farm's
productivity and income while serving as
stewards all with fewer resources and
higher Investments so not only are these
Farmers inherently interested in climate
resilience they're already Innovative
and putting practices into place that's
based on their own experiences
generational wisdom and cultural
Traditions we're working specifically
with historic ially excluded groups such
as Latino Latino Farmers veteran farmers
and building relationships with other
diverse communities to listen and learn
from the knowledge they hold in the
challenges that they are facing as part
of our role in the climate smart
Commodities grant that you all heard
about from Julie we're working to
promote adaptation and resilience
practices that farmers are able to apply
at scale this is going to include
Pathways to financial compensation which
needs to be farmer and forward Equitable
and accessible thank
you hi my name is j mcfaden a dairy
Academy nutritionist and Professor here
in Department of animal science my work
focuses on livestock methan and so we
sort of have two two key categories one
is to enhance the efficiency of milk
production in developing countries but
here in America we really focus on
developing safe and effective
technologies that reduce cic methane
emissions from cattle that involves
speed additives
vaccines litic enzymes that Target the
methanogens that require very extensive
um commitment to do the clinical trials
required for FDA approval of these
compounds and then second second we're
also thinking about monitoring one thing
to ask farmers to develop to use
Technologies um that are safe and
effective but at the end of the day we
have to make sure we can monitor how
those Technologies work on individual
farms and so there' be a very um
concerted effort to focus on how do you
predict or monitor those Emissions on
individual cow level which will include
very various wearable Technologies so
the things that we're doing here at
cordal is to upscale our infrastructure
re research capabilities faculty U and
equipment to be able to do this at the
skill uh that is required thank
you hi everyone my name is Amy Barkley
I'm the livestock and beginning Farm
specialist with the Southwest New York
Dairy livestock and field crops program
I'm working with a team of Educators
across the state um with another team of
35 Broiler meat bird producers across
the state to determine their
efficiencies of production and whether
or not their Broiler Enterprises are
economically viable next slide please
one of the unanticipated consequences
that we've run into in part due to
climate change is more extreme weather
events and as part of these more extreme
weather events we're seeing higher
condemnations of the birds slower growth
rates and essentially um higher death
rates among flocks making them less
profitable for Farmers going forward
because these birds are a keystone
species for many farms it's very
important for us to make sure that these
birds grow well and we're taking the
information learned from this study to
provide producers across the state with
information on how to grow Birds most
effectively thank
you good afternoon um my name is Bobby
Severson and I'm an extension associate
and director of The Cooperative
Enterprise program in the Dyson school
and I'm just going to speak a little bit
about the Cooperative opportunities for
grazing sheep beneath utility scale
solar arrays next slide at the
succession suggestion of the American
Solar grazing Association and through
funding with USDA Agricultural Marketing
service a survey was developed launched
and completed by 400 Farmers to examine
the need for a farmer-owned organization
such as a co-op to provide services to
overcome barriers to sheep grazing under
solar rays particular focus is on the
needs of 50 farmers are AAR Farmers
presently grazing under solar arrays and
20 229 B Farmers which is almost 60%
with sheep and are interested in grazing
under arrays we found there is a need
for such an organization with initial
Focus to negotiate contracts and Prov
insurance with increased um anticipated
increased number of sheep there is also
a need for additional marketing
Slaughter and processing facilities and
with that we're next slide we've got
some resources that we're putting up
that um include a resource guide and a
spreadsheet hey everybody my name is
David K I was on the Stellar organizing
committee I also want to call out Jen in
particular for leading us I think she
deserves a round of
applause already held everything
together um so we're going to go into a
discussion session now I see you I'm
checking with her make sure I don't
screw up um and as usual story 15
minutes basically we'll come back and
we'll have our last round of lightning
talks um and I'll reintroduce myself now
that's it what is one way you could
build on your current specialty to help
your clients contribute to the New York
State climate smart goals which we've
been hearing about from a number of
people again like you know I think it's
obvious what we're trying to do here
trying to get people to think how you
could integrate all of this into your
own work that's point of almost all of
this so please go ahead and uh I hope
you find some somebody to talk to or
some thoughts that really inspire you
and give you some little more concrete
uh vision of how you will move forward
with this work individually and together
with colleagues thank
you I know uh it's not like we always
saved the best for last and we're
certainly not doing that I'm talking
about the audience members as well as
our speakers um we're not saving the
best or less but we are saving some
really great presentations to wrap
things up um I'm going to just briefly
introduce myself again a little bit more
David Kay I'm the department extension
leader in the department of global
development I'm also I'm GNA ask you all
a question here how many of you have
climate somewhere in your titles your
job titles or your work plan
descriptions actually that's pretty good
let's give a round of applause for
those how many of you work who don't
have that work on CL St let's have a
hand for those
folks now let me ask how many of you
have heard of the national extension
climate
initiative great I'm going to encourage
all of those you raised your hands who
I'm going to just assume by default are
members uh which just means signing up
on our mailing list may not be true um
and encourage everybody else to check it
out this is like your peers across the
spectrum of of extension working on
everything that they Define as having
something to do with climate uh trying
to up the potential of our entire land
grant University system to work on
climate more effectively uh seeking
resources sharing information so I
encourage you to check that out I'm
bringing up because I am chair and our
absolutely fabulous keynote speaker over
here Jenny Whitman is one of our
committee chairpersons so on the
curriculum committee so and cor Cornell
and New York are already well
represented as you may have seen but uh
we would love to have everybody at least
aware of what we're doing last thing I'm
just going to say a little bit more kind
of along the lines of what um of what
the other folks coming out will do is I
just want to mention I was mentioned in
earlier session that if uh we get
funding from doe this is something I'm
personally involved in we will have an
incredible
opportunity in collaboration with nerta
formally and with a whole bunch of other
Statewide organizations who are also
very interested in trying
to have extension in the Forefront of
helping
communities plann for and accommodate
the amount of large scale Renewables
which New York really means solar for
the most part more effectively we would
have sort of old sighting project that
would get going and there's explicitly
they're explicitly hoping that uh doe is
hoping that and they ask for extension
to be in the lead in applying for this
money uh so New York may or may not be
one of the lucky ones but more to come
on that and with that I'm going to turn
it over to Jack and also mention that we
do have a Mis representer so your job is
going to be trying to guess who is
listed up on the previous slide which
you can't even see anymore and compare
them to who has actually
presented hello everyone uh my name is
Jack Wright uh I am the PowerHouse
educator uh here at CCE Tomkins as part
of the energy and climate change team um
next slide please the PowerHouse is a
tiny home that was built with Energy
Efficiency in mind uh and we used to as
a mobile educational resource um
specifically uh for youth education so
we'll do programs with um folks in
grades T through 12 uh and do Hands-On
exhibits to um help folks understand
more about how we use energy so there's
three main things that we try to instill
in our lessons um especially for younger
kids it's just understanding what uses
energy in our home and then of course
how we can use less of it um second is
to understand where that energy comes
from and finally to understand how
energy and our energy use acts the
climate um so if you or someone you know
is interested in talking more about
youth education um especially around
climate please feel free to email me or
catch me up the talks
thanks it's not a lack of information or
climate change denial that holds people
back it's often a sense of confusion
discouragement at the enormity of the CH
Challenge and a feeling of what can I as
one person do to counter this Despair
and hopelessness we need to create
connection contion and belonging be the
Catalyst for a group of people find
people where they already are where they
already have connections and start a
movement what works when we are in the
company of others taking action getting
support feeling Community doing it
together that works work with spiritual
organizations with neighborhoods with
nonprofits with knitting clubs with
soccer teams whatever the main thing is
to strengthen and maintain the personal
connections to start climate
conversations to get climate actions
going to spread the energy and the ideas
reach far more people this way move them
to concern and action go forth and
multiply you don't have to have any
special skills to start doing this
tomorrow hi I'm Jackie spencor community
and economic Vitality from CC shimang
and my coworker Tony Gardner and natural
resources and we're just highlighting a
workshop series that we worked on
together uh clear the Clutter so um
Community need that came to us was a
need for folks to have information on
keeping their home environments
maintained well and so we launched this
four session workshop for ad dogs
exploring personal preferences around
organizational prioritizing needs
letting go of possessions and making a
plan and the audience had a strong
desire to reduce reuse recycle and keep
things from going into landfills so um
we brought in Tony for uh one of our
sessions and she'll talk about that um
we will I will be offering a cc educator
session this winter for folks that might
want to rec replicate the series and the
participant feedback was overwhelmingly
positive especially emphasizing the
inclusion of the household management
resources right thank you Jackie so we
were talking about the hazardous waste
and that was my uh focus when I went
into the group but that it is a clutter
class so we talked a lot about clutter
throughout the home people do have a lot
of clutter in their garage I'm sure that
all of you do it creeps up on us um
before you even know it you have a whole
bunch of something most home homes are f
f with belongings that you no longer
have a need for um and how did I relate
this to climate I let them know that oh
de sorry decluttering can be bad for the
environment if you don't take the time
and care to consider where your items
will end
up hello uh I'm not Gabriel dirty I'm
your surprised guest um so Gabriel's uh
having a medical emergency right now um
but he should be fine um so I am GED Ms
I am Gabriel's I guess supervisor
through this program egg energy n which
is an is certa program Statewide looking
at energy use on farms and um it covers
all farm sectors except for dairy and
Green Houses which are covered by other
programs um and essentially it provides
education resources for CCE Educators
who then work with their communities and
their farmers in their counties um as
well as some of the area uh egg teams um
we also just got some Foundation money
separate from nerta to do additional
work that Gabriel's taking on in terms
of um some of the incentives and rebates
that are available so he can help folks
actually access the money to do the
energy upgrades um and also we're going
to hire a full-time person to do ad and
solar work um so helping Farmers
understand the whole a solar landscape
um so that's exciting um and that'll be
coming up Statewide we have brochures on
the program and that's the website
essentially and um I'll put these on the
back table
thanks Kim beer is director of the
Southern Tier Regional clean energy Hub
out of popular extension pumkin County
so you've heard about nerta our state
energy agency and you've heard about the
clcpa or state energy act and in the
coming decades billions of dollars are
going to be invested in clean energy and
the ACT says that at least 35% of
benefits should go to disad anage
communities and how is that going to
happen well this isn't the total answer
but part of that is that the regional
hubs were created by nerta to serve
disadvantaged communities providing
resources on clean energy use um
reducing energy and accessing clean
energy jobs next
slide TW there are 12 hubs in 10
regions seven uh have SE CCE involvement
with dozens of associations and four of
the hubs are led by CCE so there are
Educators in almost each County of our
region looking to collaborate with other
uh Educators and programs to reach this
population and help make people's homes
cleaner safer and Greener thank
you thank you thank you thank you to all
of our lightning talk speakers today can
we have a final round of applause for
everyone we truly appreciate your
willingness to take on the challenge of
a one minute presentation we know it
wasn't easy but we appreciate your
patience with us um and your energy and
all of the information resources that
you shared
today um as we move into the final um
portion of our afternoon I would like to
welcome up uh Jenny C niffin interim
director of CCE and associate professor
in the school integrative PL science for
some concluding remarks before we move
into a final discussion question thank
you all for coming and thank you Jenna
for for really leading this on I'll have
to say that so Jenna said can you just
talk about why we're doing this so that
everyone knows the context so the
context goes way way back but I'll just
say in the most recent time it was one
year ago we had the Agriculture and
service you know we were still in this
kind of a hybrid phase covid-19 part
virtual and part in person so the
virtual part of it was on a Monday and
the focus was on
climate and energy and so Ben Holton was
our keynote speaker for that and then we
had these two amazing brand new climate
resiliency specialist Jenna and Zach
well Zach moved to Oregon I'm really
happy to see we have a new yes the
vanish onut everyone knows you and and
so that's very exciting and we're hoping
more to come very very soon and so in
this phenomenal what you and Zach
created was this amazing um followup
after Ben Holton and we gave we gave Ben
Holton a little bit of the summary of
what happened and he was just he was so
excited so we spoke with Ben ferus and
Ben Holton was very excited that you
know compared to other universities with
these really large climate types of
programs you know this would be a un one
because of the extension program many of
those other universities like Stanford
don't have a Statewide extension program
so this is quite unique to Corell and it
carries on this Legacy um so again as
we're concluding Jenna thank you Jenny
Whitman that I got to see in person he
really exciting to see her in person uh
Kitty O'Neal right there and David K
Nancy Glazier Laura mcdermit antonus
chest Jr and Kathy bunting Howard
Savanah shelnut and Sarah musio are all
part of the the initial climate
Symposium organizing committee now this
the original idea came from the ground
up so I'll have to say that Chris
Watkins who was our director of cornal
Cooperative Extension from 2014 up until
just recently July 2023 he really wanted
this to happen the climate specialist
climate resiliency specialist he had a
vision for just having so many more of
this all across the state the expansion
of the regional a teams and the whole
purpose was that so many and I mentioned
the organizers so many have this climate
focus it wasn't forced upon it was
voluntary it was voluntary and it was
because everyone the a Specialists and
harvest New York as
well their their job is to connect to
the stakeholders the communities and
this is what they felt the need is all
across the state and nothing has ever
been forced and so it's always been
ground up bottom up and that was the way
Chris Watkins LED we have a new director
coming December 1st Andy Turner can you
stand up again in case people missed it
for your lightning
C so Andy was one of the first speakers
for the lightning talk and so that's a
good sign so that tells you that carries
on this interest in having a director
that really cares about climate and
energy and so with that it's really
Andy's you know Andy gets all the
wonderful opportunities to to work with
everybody and how do we have that vision
for the future and so another important
part is you know Julie Suarez who was
our speaker our keynote speaker has done
some amazing work we always know Julie
for county law 224 funding in January
but I hope you were delighted to see
that leadership and pioneering aspect of
Julie jie and so Julie has already left
the building I believe and so hasn't
heard uh this part of it and then also
just to note we had Mike Hoffman here
and also Allison churchan that was here
and so many of you may have known um
many years back that they pioneered a
lot of this climate smart farming and
and also got to work with a on
continuing to do this work on climate
stewards so this is where I just want to
leave just to say that a lot of this
work was happening a lot of this and I
was telling Jenna it was a lot of Chris
Watkins wanting us to just continue on
in this now we have Andy Turner to
continue on this role and we have more
to come Keith tidle helped with some of
these remarks but I will I will know
that there's a lot of pressure and David
K Contin can continue on with the
pressure of how do we have this at the
leadership level in CCE Administration
so there's more to come very very
quickly but it's not my place to reveal
how that will happen but it's always
going to be from the ground of and it's
always going to be you know from what
the egg specialist EG Educators around
the state are interested in and already
doing so thank you everyone for being
here contributing to the lightning talks
and being interested and maybe we'll
actually have a climat on it very soon
thank
you all right sure everyone's starting
to get fatigu so we are at nearing the
end um we have one last
prompt before that I just wanted to have
you all give yourselves a round of
applause for being
here it takes motivated educators to
actually make a difference motiv to
actually change community and create
community so um I also wanted to again
thank the committee thank all the
speakers today um Jenny and Jenna I was
just talking with Savannah and Jenna
doesn't give herself enough credit for
things so thank you again
Jenna really spearheaded the whole thing
and gave me a chance to actually be up
here um so our last prompt
is somewhat personal but also relating
right back to everything while we're
here so what do you need individually
organizationally and in your community
to further your climate work we all have
our own Niche and what we like to do
what we want to do and so what do you
need um this is your chance to share
your thoughts we have some prompt cards
and some pens available for you to write
down your responses they're being handed
out um committee members will be
collecting these around the room and in
the box at the back so please feel free
to work together to
brainstorm and discuss this um and then
we will have 15 minutes of that and then
we will regroup for closing remarks so
so thank you all
again just some final announcements for
everybody heads out the
door so to continue the momentum of
today if you're interested in joining um
with other colleagues to continue
discussions um one option is the
Agriculture and climate change program
work team or another of the program work
teams out of Cornell
um hear so on the back of the program
you can see the QR code on the top will
take you to the website where you can
join those program work
teams and then finally as you're leaving
today or afterwards we'll send this in a
followup email um you can take our
survey that we have here it's very short
I promise and just to give us feedback
on today's event and any future events
what you would like to see and thank you
again for to everyone for coming
today
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu